que voulez-vous la table pour non monsieur moi
jamais utilisé d'armes
el chapo que son trafiquant de drogue plus
important du Mexique sa capture est un
victoire contre le trafic de drogue
joaquin où vas-tu ils ne peuvent pas
attendre à
Pourquoi ne me dis-tu pas une fois ce que tu veux
le nom patron moi
l'attendu
Pourquoi mon père m'a-t-il appelé qui m'a ?
que dire car c'est encore un chat
plus que des trafiquants de drogue
Je serai à moi ce duel génétique de la ville
pour le meurtre du cardinal
guadalajara
j'ai déjà une certaine
maintenant si personne ne me paie
J'ai prié pour toi tous les jours
parce que je suis éternel